and across the country we're starting to
see various public and government
agencies require vaccinations or
now routine testing for those who are
unvaccinated kate houston spoke to our
local va about
mandating vaccines and she breaks down
how they came to this decision and also
if other public employees could be
required as well
we're seeing definitely an overwhelming
of our health care systems in general
the v.a requiring medical staff to get
the kovid 19 vaccine
our patients of veterans are first and
foremost and they have already suffered
as they fought for freedom so to equal
that with our service
then that's where we want to do our best
to protect them from disease
dr jason daisley with the va southern
nevada health care system
says 99 percent of their staff already
has their shots
he thinks other entities will follow
they're going to want to
make it something where we can increase
our vaccination numbers
a little bit because we're like in the
low 40s and that's not nearly where we
need to be
while the state works to bring
percentages up at this time it is not
requiring employees to get the vaccine
but it doesn't end there
state employees who are unvaccinated
will be required to take weekly program
19 tests
last week dwane young with the
governor's office stated tests will
begin mid-august
they're encouraging employees to get
vaccinated before then
state government workplaces that reach
more than 70 of a vaccination of
employees
will no longer need to follow the weekly
testing protocol
when it comes to whether clark county
will mandate employee vaccinations a
representative says they're evaluating
their options
kate houston 8 news now metro police
will require
all new hires regardless of position to
be vaccinated
but it's still optional for current
employees and as of monday only 51
percent of metro employees have been
fully vaccinated